there will be funerals today for two
more shooting victims 14-year old Elena
petit and 15 year-old Luke Hoyer
services will be held for at least five
more victims later this week 14 students
and three adults were killed in
Wednesday's shooting the community
honored 14 year old Alec Schachter 14
year old Jamie Guttenberg and 35 year
old geography teacher Scott beagle
yesterday beagle students say he tried
to shield them from the gunman it was
just the best teacher ever you he
automatically made you smile no matter
what he said you know he always had to
come back to everything nothing he was a
great man and most important he was a
hero to a lot of people and I still
don't believe it like I still think I'm
gonna go back to his class and
everything but yeah it still hasn't hit
me and it was just too shit's too
shocking I hit me
he didn't nobody deserved it especially
him he was hands down like favorite
teacher ever
yeah I think time is what's gonna heal
all of us if it even does but just
walking into that mr. Biba's classroom
and not him like him not being there I'm
not walking walking into that front door
where he was when he passed you know how
are we supposed to do that without you
know balling into tears like I don't
understand
we just need time and just being with
friends that were there that survived
being with each other that's helping but
it's not something you can just push and
like get out no you like you can't get
over this